il est arrivé sous la pluie au volant du
bolide qu'il conduisait pour la deuxième
fois depuis son accident autour de lui
une meute de photographes qui le harcèle
stoïque l'autrichien considère que c'est
la rançon de la gloire
sur le plan physique le champion du
monde semble rétabli plus de fractures
mais encore les traces de ces terribles
brûlures l'accident c'était il ya 40
jours sur le nürburgring qu'il n'aimait
pas d'ailleurs
il avait fait savoir aux journalistes
avant le drame quarante jours de
souffrance et le voici à nouveau au
volant
certains parlent de miracle lauda lui
expliquent ces semaines de lutte
[Musique]
depuis l'accident ni qui je suis resté
une semaine entre les mains des
chirurgiens puis une autre à l'hôpital
de mannheim réservé pour grands brûlés
et puis je suis rentré chez moi et j'ai
repris mon entraînement physique je suis
parti ensuite quatre jours à ibiza en
vacances c'est là que vous avez décidé
de revenir aussi vite à la compétition
non j'ai pris la décision il ya deux
semaines lorsque les examens pulmonaires
et sanguins se sont révélés positifs
alors alors seulement je me suis remis à
l'entraînement est-ce que vous souffrez
encore non pas du tout vous est rétabli
à 100 pour cent oui c'était votre
premier accident et qui oui enfin disons
est mon premier accident grave
si vous avez pensé ne plus être en
mesure de piloter en reprenant vos
esprits en sortant du coma vous savez la
première semaine est dans un état très
critique mais je ne pouvais exactement
réalisé la gravité de mes blessures
lorsque j'ai repris conscience que ça
allait mieux alors je n'ai pas
désespérée vous croyez que votre
condition physique nous a aidés mais je
crois j'ai été sauvée parce que
physiquement j'étais en pleine forme
si par exemple j'avais fumé il audard je
serais mort maintenant dans quel état
d'esprit abordez t-il ce retour on ici à
monza je vais faire attention c'est ma
première course après plus d'un mois
d'une action
je ne peux espérer gagner je vais
m'entraîner m'habituer doucement par
contre au grand prix du canada j'espère
être en mesure de l'emporter
henri pescarolo lui aussi victime d'un
drame semblable explique les motivations
du pilote
on n'a qu'une seule hâte après un
accident grave c'est de se retrouver à
soi même surtout de retrouver aux autres
qu'on est toujours le même et qu'on n'a
rien perdu et
s'il veut défendre valablement ses
chances dans les dernières courses et
valachie dans le commence très tôt parce
que alors par contre quand on reprend
après un accident
on risque de
elle est un peu plus tôt accélérer un
peu moins à deux reprises
c'est ce qu'on veut prouver justement et
se prouver à soi même parce qu'on est
de savoir comment on réagit après un
accident et personnellement pendant tout
le temps que j'étais sur mon lit à
l'hôpital je n'avais qu'une hâte c'était
de remonter dans une voiture de course
pour prouver que j'étais capable de
conduire comme avant et je crois que
c'est ce que veut faire mais qui est je
crois que lui-même en ce moment n'est
pas capable de savoir s'il y aura aussi
vite qu'avant
vous aviez pensé l'accident avant oui je
sais que c'est un sport dangereux
d'ailleurs chacun djouad parmi nous en
être conscient l'ancien champion du
monde jackie stewart est quand même
surpris de revoir le drame c'est
normalement la couleur automobile après
l'accident tout c'est minimum trois
quatre mois pour nourrir ces noms moment
une typo un petit peu miracle pour
l'équité gros miracle condition
maintenant c'est très fort de physique
bien deux
oui
maintenant arrêter
il faut c'est pour le championnat du
monde n'est pas nécessaire mozart comme
pour l'équipe c'est possible ici deux
trois points pour le championnat du
monde c'est très important
l'épi location que vous n'êtes pas là
pour vous entraîner mais bien pour
marquer des points au championnat du
monde
non ici je ne pense pas au championnat à
la seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est de
faire une bonne course pour moi même
après 40 jours de maladie
si personnellement tout marche bien
alors je serais très heureux vous auriez
cru à monza
[Musique]
ne parlons pas du titre d'îlots dame est
désormais j'espère avoir un peu de
chance pour la fin de saison
vous allez vous battre comme avant je me
bats toujours de la même façon
lauda aujourd'hui a réussi le cinquième
temps absolu des essais au grand prix
d'italie
chapeau
[Musique]